في تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا اعلنت
وسائل اعلام الروسيه ان مطارات موسكو
تستانف حركه الملاحه بشكل طبيعي بعد تقييد
الرحلات الجويه لمده ساعه على خلفيه اسقاط
المسايره في ضواحي موسكو وكان عمده بوسكو
اكد ان الدفاعات الجويه
في منطقه استرا بيضواحي العاصمه وفي
بيلجورد اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
دفاعاتها الجويه دمرت طائره اوكرانيه
مسيره فوق اراضي منطقه
شبيكينسكي في المقابل قياده القوات الجويه
الاوكرانيه انها دمرت مسيرتين من نوع شاهد
في مقاطعات
شمال شرقي البلاد
نذهب الى اسكندم الينا من هناك مراسلنا
مازن ابراهيم ومن موسكو مراسلنا ايضا نور
الدين الدغير ماذا نبدا معك باخر التطورات
الميدانيه وايضا حرب المسيرات
نعم في الواقع بالنسبه للمسيرات واطلاقها
باتجاه الاراضي الروسيه او فوق شبه جزيره
القرم يمكن القول ان هذه المعادله
العسكريه التي ارسلتها القياده الاوكرانيه
باتت ركنا اساسيا من اركان التكتيكات التي
تتبعها في المواجهه المفتوحه وضمن اطار
الهجوم المضاد الذي اطلقته قبل ان نحوي
شهرين ونصف عمليا القوات الاوكرانيه باتت
تعتمد على هذه المسيرات في الوصول الى عمق
الاراضي الروسيه ومقاطعه موسكو والعاصمه
موسكو وذلك لاهداف متعدده في طلعتها
الايرباك النفسي والمعنوي في ايصال هكذا
نوع من المسيرات الى عاصمه دوله كبرى دوله
عظمى تخوض معركه وبالتالي تحاول القياده
العسكريه الاوكرانيه القول ان كل استهداف
العمق الاوكراني يقابله وصول الى العمق
الروسي وان كانت القدره التدميريه لهذه
المسيرات هي حتى هذه اللحظه ما زالت رمزيه
اما على مستوى المسيرات صواريخ التي تطلق
باتجاه شبه جزيره القرنفل هنا مختلفه نوعا
ما وهي تحمل عده اعتبارات بالنسبه للقياده
الاوكرانيه سواء على المستوى العسكري او
على المستوى المدني السياسي وذلك على
اعتبار بانها تريد ان تؤكد بان شبه جزيره
القرم هي جزء اساسي من التراب الاوكراني
من السياده الاوكرانيه وبالتالي من لا
يفرط بشبه جزيره القرم تلقائيا لا يمكن له
ان يفرط على طاوله المفاوضات او في الحرب
على المقاطعات الاربعه التي اعلنت روسيا
ضمها اليها وبالتالي من هنا يمكن ان نفهم
بان هذا التكثيف في العمليات الخاصه سواء
من خلال الانزال الذي حصل في شبه الجزيره
او من خلال الاستهداف بهذا الكم الكبير من
المسيرات هو ضمن اطار واضح ورمزي وايضا
معنوي واسع وعسكري وهنا لم يكن من باب
المصادفه ان ياتي كل هذا التكثيف الرمزي
لهذه الاستهدافات يوم الرابع من الشهر قبل
يومين في عيد استقلال اوكرانيا وبالتالي
اريد لهذا الانزال الذي حصل في شبه جزيره
الكرم وما اعقبه من عشرات المسيرات التي
ضربت تلك المنطقه سواء وصلت الى اهدافها
او تم اسقاطها ان توصل الرساله واضحه بانه
في عيد الاستقلال اوكرانيا وانطلاقا من
هذه اللحظه التاريخيه وفق ما تريد ان
تقوله القياده الاوكرانيه فانها لن تفرط
بوحده السياده الاوكرانيه على كامل ترابها
على مستوى المواجهه الميدانيه هي ما زالت
مستعره على عده جبهات وان كانت الجبهه
الرئيسيه حاليا هي جبهه مقاطعه زابوروجيا
حيث تمكنت بالفعل القوات الاوكرانيه من
اختراق خضه دفاع الاول للقوات الروسيه
تحديدا في روبوتينو من هناك وفق كل
التقديرات سواء كانت الغربيه او حتى
الامريكيه من خلال مراكز الدراسات او ما
يصدر عن خبراء عسكريين امريكيين وغربيين
من الواضح بان القياده الاوكرانيه من خلال
قواتها تمكنت من اختراق خط الدفاع الاول
والان المواجهات تحصل خط الدفاع الثاني
وهذا الامر له دلالات عسكريه كبيره تعول
عليها القياده الاوكرانيه من خلال سباق مع
الزمن من الان وحتى نهايه شهر سبتمبر ضمن
الاسابيع المتبقيه قبل ان يتغير المناخ في
محاوله منها لقطع طريق خط الامداد الذي
يصل من داخل الاراضي الروسيه باتجاه شبه
جزيره الكرم عبر مقاطعه
ايضا الى نور الدين دغيا في موسكو
والروايه الروسيه خاصه في متعلق بهذه
المسيرات نعم ليس الامر بالجديد انها تصل
الى عمق العاصمه موسكو ولكن في تكرارها
الكثير من الارباك اليس كذلك
هناك يوميات تسمى بيوميات الحرب هنا ما
بين روسيا وما بين اوكرانيا وبالتالي سواء
المسيرات او المواجهات على الجبهات على
الارض ما بين قوات المشاه اصبح جزءا يوميا
من هذه الحرب المشتعله ما بين البلدين بكل
تاكيد وصول المسيرات هو استراتيجيه
اوكرانيه ربما قد تشكل نوعا من الازعاج او
حتى نوع من الارباك لروسيا لكن دائما
الجواب الروسي انه لحد الساعه هذه
المسيرات لم تستطع الوصول الى الاهداف
التي ربما قد رسمت لها وقد تكون اهداف
استراتيجيه خاصه حينما نتحدث عن وصول
طائرات الى وسط عاصمه موسكو او الى مناطق
عسكريه ولا تصل الاهداف فبالتالي هنا
الجانب الروسي يتحدث على انه لحد الساعه
قد تمكن بشكل كبير من احباط هذه المحاولات
بشقين وبعمليه
عسكريين منفصلين الشكل الاول وهو عبر
استعمال الدفاعات الجويه وهو شكل تقليدي
تعرفت عليه الحروب وهناك شكل محدث من هذه
الحروب وهو التشويس الالكترو المواجهه
الالكترونيه اذا لحد الساعه الحديث
الاوكراني عن ارسال المسيرات يقابله رد
روسي عن اسقاط هذه المسيرات وعدم وصولها
الى اماكنها لكن بكل تاكيد وصول اي مسيره
او اي هجوم بمسيارات هنا يقابل برد اخر من
الجانب الروسي وبالتالي الرد الروسي ربما
على مستوى النوع وعلى مستوى الكيف قد
يتوافق يتفوق بشكل كبير على الهجوم
الاوكراني باعتبار ان روسيا تغير في طبيعه
الاسلحه المستعمله سواء عبر الصواريخ
الباليستيه عبر الصواريخ المجنحه او عبر
المسيرات وهو ما تقوم به في استهداف
العديد من المواقع سواء في الاوديسه او
بكير او بخاركين او بصومي او في غرب
اوكرانيا كل هذه الاجراءات تقوم بها
اوكرانيا لكن دائما يطرح السؤال حينما
تنطلق مسيره اوكرانيا او مسيرات اوكرانيا
واذا ما رجعنا الى الهجوم الكبير الذي صنف
هنا في روسيا على انه اكبر هجوم بالمسيرات
الاوكرانيه على شبه جزيره القرم دائما
يطرح السؤال ما هي الوجهه التي كانت
تقصدها هذه المسيرات وما هو الهدف بكل
تاكيد الجواب العسكري هنا ان هذه المسيرات
تقريبا تحدد اهدافها سواء على مستوى مواقع
وتمركز القوات الروسيه والتدريب ومراكز
تدريب القوات الروسيه على مستوى الدفاعات
الجويه باعتبار انها لحد الساعه الدفاعات
الجويه الروسيه باعتبار تملكها ترسانه
كبيره ومتنوعه من الدفاعات الجويه تمنع اي
توغل عبر الاجواء واستهداف المقرات والمقر
الرسميه والمهمه على المستوى العسكري وعلى
المستوى الامني وعلى المستوى السياسي
وكذلك على مستوى الذخيره والعتاد لكن في
المقابل تقول روسيا اما استهدافتها بكل
تاكيد تستهدف مواقع تجميع وارسال المسيرات
وكذلك مواقع الذخيره وبكل تاكيد هذا
سينعكس ايجابا او سلبا على المواقع على
الارض ماذا تريد روسيا على الارض بكل
تاكيد تريد الحفاظ على مواقعها وهو ما
يحدث في جنوب دنيات والتقدم الى الامام
باتجاه القوات الاوكرانيه وباتجاه الاخر
كيف وهذا ما يحدث في الشمال والشمال
الغربي باتجاه الكوبيس نور الدين غير
مراسل الجزيره من موسكو مازال ابراهيم
مراسل الجزيره من سلوفيانس شكرا جزيلا
لكما